das ist eine sensationelle entdeckung
fachleute haben gravitationswellen eines
zuvor noch nie beobachteten ereignisses
aufgespürt und die gravitationswellen
sind wirklich sehr besonders und
unterscheiden sich deutlich von dem
typischen muster dass fachleute bisher
kennen es beginnt quasi eine neue ära
der gravitationswellen forschung klicks
um science-fiction hier gibt es drei mal
pro woche spannendes seines videos
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocke nur dann verpasst ihr nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen klicks und
gibt es jetzt übrigens auch als podcast
für unterwegs die links zu spotify und
apple podcast in unten in der video
beschreibung und dann bekommt der klicks
um auch auf die ohren
die gravitationswellen um die es geht
wurden am zwölften april des vorigen
jahres 2019 aufgespürt wie jetzt
mitgeteilt wurde genau zwei wochen nach
beginn der dritten saison als die
fachleute die sensibilität der beiden
laico detektoren in den usa und dem
italienischen bürger detector deutlich
erhöht hatten erst dadurch wurde die
detektion dieses ungewöhnlichen sechsmal
so wohl auch erst möglich und die
beobachtung ist wirklich eine ganz
besondere denn das signal entspricht
ganz und gar nicht dem typischen muster
der bislang aufgespürten
gravitationswellen die fachleute haben
das ereignis gg 19 04 1 2 getauft
besonders spannend finden die forscher
aus den usa und italien die obertöne die
auftreten hierbei handelt es sich wohl
um schwingungen mit einem vielfachen der
grundfrequenz diese beobachtungen sind
zwar auf den ersten blick äußerst
rätselhaft dennoch lassen sie spannende
rückschlüsse zu die es tatsächlich
ermöglichen der mysteriösen quelle
dieser gravitationswellen auf die
schliche zu kommen was wirklich eine
ziemliche detektivarbeit war aber am
schluss haben sie es heraus bekommen
eigentlich kann man schon fast behaupten
dass die messung von gravitationswellen
zur routine geworden ist fachleute
sprachen zuletzt von etwa einem
registrierten gravitationswellen
ereignis pro woche und das obwohl er es
vor vier jahren 2016 die erste
sensationelle messung von
gravitationswellen bekannt gegeben
worden war 2017 gab es dann zu recht den
physik nobelpreis an rainer weiß gifhorn
und barry bayerisch das ganze war
spannender als jeder krimi
und hat nicht weniger als eine komplette
neue ära der physik eingeläutet es
begann am 14 september 2015 um 551
amerikanischer ortszeit rainer weis war
verreist und lag zu dieser uhrzeit noch
im bett weit weg von seinen beiden
kilometer langen den lektoren die
plötzlich erzitterten fehlalarm nein
denn stattdessen war es der große moment
der von jetzt auf gleich alles
veränderte nach jahrzehntelanger suche
hatte man endlich gravitationswellen
gemessen ausgelöst durch den
zusammenstoß von zwei schwarzen löchern
und wie immer in der wissenschaft ist
solch eine entdeckung noch deutlich mehr
wert wenn sie wiederholt werden kann und
tatsächlich auch folgende messungen
bestätigten den nachhall solcher
kollisionen unter anderem konnten
gravitationswellen detektiert werden
deren ursache die kollision von zwei
neutronensternen war eine sensation für
die wissenschaftswelt allein durch das
belauschen der raumzeit schwingung waren
forschungsteams also in diesem zeitpunkt
in der lage kosmische phänomene
aufzuspüren selbst diejenigen die keine
oder nur wenig elektromagnetische
strahlung freisetzen also nicht mit
radioteleskopen zum beispiel beobachtet
werden konnten das war der
wissenschaftswelt bisher verborgen
geblieben im wahrsten sinne des wortes
nur noch mal zur verdeutlichung
gravitation ist ein effekt der in der
allgemeinen relativitätstheorie
beschrieben wird große massen
komprimieren raum und zeit spricht die
räume werden kleiner und die zeit läuft
langsamer hier auf der erde kann man das
ganz wunderbar demonstrieren wenn wir
aufspringen werden wir durch die
komprimierung des raums wieder auf die
erde gezogen es gibt keine kraft die uns
hier auf die erde zieht es ist ein
relativistische effekt und unsere füße
die sind jünger als unser kopf weil für
die die zeit unten auf der erde wo die
kaffeesatz ion direkt auf der erde
stärker ist langsamer läuft deshalb
gehen auch die uhren auf den gps
satelliten dort oben anders weil sie
sonst einfach nicht funktionieren würden
denn für sie läuft die zeit wiederum
schneller als sie unten auf der erde und
wenn zwei große objekte zusammenstoßen
dann verändert sich die gravitation und
zwar in wellen seit der ersten
entdeckung haben die beiden lager und
detektoren in den usa und der bürger und
den sektor in italien dutzende solcher
raumzeit erschütterung aufgespürt
verschmelzen dabei schwarze löcher mit
dabei sind aber auch neutronenstern
kollisionen und sogar auch die ungleiche
paarung mit einem neutronenstern und
einem schwarzen loch die wurden so
entdeckt dennoch kommt es immer wieder
zu überraschungen und rekorden sowie die
anfang des vorigen jahres 2019 damals
gab es vier weitere neuzugänge und mit
dabei auch die massereichste und am
weitesten entfernte gravitationswellen
quelle die bislang je gemessen wurde die
rede ist von dem ereignis namens gw 17
07 29 bei dieser verschmelzung wurden
knapp 5 sonnenmassen in
gravitationswellen umgewandelt also das
ist eine unglaubliche menge an energie
die in dieser gravitationswellen
geflossen ist die energiemenge die dabei
freigesetzt wird muss wirklich eben
unvorstellbar gigantisch gewesen seien
entdeckt wurden sie im früheren
aufzeichnungen der gravitationswellen
observatorien laico in den usa und
bürger in italien hier laufen die
messung in einem sogenannten interferenz
experiment bei dem ein laserstrahl in
zwei teile strahlen aufgespalten wird
die lichtwellen wenn in zwei röhren
geleitet die exakt gleich lang sind und
senkrecht aufeinander stehen also im 90
grad winkel
am ende steht ein spiegel der sie
reflektiert und zurückwirft wenn sich
die strahlen im normalfall aufheben gibt
es kein signal
die beiden laser löschen sich
gegenseitig aus weil sie ja aus einem
laser stammt und dieselbe frequenz haben
legt man sie dann ebenso übereinander
und genau das wird gemacht dass bei dem
ein leser signal an wellenberg ist
während zur gleichen zeit bei dem
anderen leser signal an wellental ist
dann löschen sich die beiden signale
gegenseitig aus es ist nichts mehr zu
sehen wenn jetzt aber auf dem leser weg
die raumzeit durch eine
gravitationswellen gekrümmt wird dann
verschieben sich die wellen der leser
unterschiedlich räumlich und zeitlich da
sie um 90 grad gedreht sind und sie
löschen sich nicht mehr gegenseitig aus
es gibt einen lichtblitz der durch dauer
stärke und veränderung sehr genaue
rückschlüsse auf das ereignis zuletzt
das große problem hierbei ist allerdings
dass die messungen sehr sehr genau sein
müssen also wenn dann nur ein lkw zu
dicht an einer röhre vorbeifährt dann
ist alles
hin also der effekt der
gravitationswellen ist so minimal klein
das alles in der nähe stören würde
solche spannende neue einzeln entdeckung
ergeben für die fachwelt stück für stück
ein gesamtbild dieser super spannenden
gravitationswellen ereignisse
es handelt sich um stauchungen und
dehnungen in struktur von raum und zeit
die sich mit lichtgeschwindigkeit
wellenförmig ausbreiten und die hatte
tatsächlich also diese veränderung diese
wellen hat tatsächlich albert an stand
schon vor mehr als 100 jahren
vorhergesagt dazu schülerin von der
university of glasgow
die wissenschaft hat einen jahrhundert
gebraucht um einsteins vorhersagen zu
bestätigen doch das tempo unserer
entdeckung hat sich seitdem enorm
beschleunigt angefangen hatte also alles
mit der relativitätstheorie von albert
einstein indem er die gravitationswellen
beschrieben hatte demnach produzieren
alle beschleunigten körper gravitations
werden also selbst werde ich hier auf
dem boden springe entsteht eine nur de
ist somit die mini minimal die würde man
wahrscheinlich nicht mehr direkt neben
mir messen können doch in den meisten
fällen eben sind sie viel zu schwach und
man kann sie nicht nachweisen
angefangen beim sprung eines menschen
bis hin zu einer sternenexplosion am
ende ihrer lebenszeit die entstehenden
gravitationswellen stauchen und strecken
den raum etwa so wie ein stein den man
ins wasser wirft und der die
wasseroberfläche kräuselt aber vor allem
große objekte im all erzeugen stärkere
gravitationswellen die man überhaupt
erst messen kann in erster linie
schwarze löcher und neutronensterne
wenn solche massen schnell genug
beschleunigt werden wird die raumzeit so
in wallung versetzt dass die
gravitationswellen auch in größerer
entfernung noch aufzuspüren sind wenn
sich die vibrationen im weltall
ausbreiten wird alles was sie passieren
in einer richtung gedehnt und in der
anderen zusammengedrückt und die zeit
wird ebenso gedehnt und gestaucht doch
selbst wenn die gravitationswellen sehr
stark sind verformen sie das weltall nur
minimal einstein dachte jedenfalls
damals im leben nicht daran dass man sie
in irgendeiner weise messen könnte die
winzigen veränderung die wären einfach
viel zu klein das war seine annahme in
diesem punkt hat er aber dann nicht
der direktor des laser interferometer
gravitationswellen observatorium sligo
in den usa david reize meinte jedenfalls
nach dem ersten nachweis im jahr 2016
vor 400 jahren hat galileo ein teleskop
auf den himmel gerichtet ich glaube wir
tun heute etwas ähnlich wichtiges wir
eröffnen eine neue ära
doch wie lässt sich das nun den
diktierte signal des ereignisses den 19
04 12 erklären dass auf den ersten blick
so viele rätsel aufgibt wie lassen sich
die identifizierten obertöne erklären
die forscher aus den usa und italien
sind sich sicher dass das mysteriöse
signal von der verschmelzung zweier
ungleicher schwarzer löcher stammt und
diese unterscheiden sich hinsichtlich
ihrer masse wohl enorm den bisherigen
analysen zufolge handelt es sich um ein
kleines schwarzes loch mit einer 8
fachen masse unserer sonne und am ein
großes schwarzes loch das die 30 fache
masse der sonne aufweist und dies hat
wohl das kleinere schwarze loch
verschlungen durch den enormen masse
unterschied kam es wohl dazu dass das
kleine schwarze loch in der schwerkraft
senke des größeren schwarzen loches
quasi umherirrte auf die kollision zu so
erklären die fachleute sich die anfangs
beschriebenen obertöne in den
freigesetzten gravitationswellen doch
die überraschenden schwingungs muster
verraten noch viele weitere spannende
informationen über die rotation und die
bahnebene der schwarzen löcher dazu der
physiker robert koss tester der an der
aktuellen studie beteiligt war das ist
das erste doppel system schwarzer löcher
bei dem wir einen so großen unterschied
zwischen den massen beobachtet haben
dieser große massen unterschied bewirkt
dass wir mehrere eigenschaften des
systems genauer messen können seinen
abstand zu uns den winkel in dem wir es
betrachten und wie schnell sich das
schwarze loch um seine achse drehen
diese beobachtung ermöglichen den
fachleuten auch den rückschluss dass die
verschmelzung der beiden ungleichen
schwarzen löcher in einer entfernung von
1,9 bis 2,9 milliarden lichtjahren
stattgefunden haben muss die analyse
legt zudem nahe dass sich das größere
der beiden schwarzen löcher wohl um
seine eigene achse dreht und zwar mit
einem spin von rund 0,4 drei das
entspricht dem rotation bereich denen
die allgemeine relativitätstheorie für
solche schwarzen
auch erlaubt hat damit zu tun dass umso
schneller sich ein schwarzes loch dreht
umso stärker ist auch die kraft die nach
außen gegen die gravitation wird also
hoch komplex heißt also im klartext dass
die beobachtung dieser sagt das ist mal
wieder einsteins allgemeine
relativitätstheorie bestätigt dazu der
max-planck- physiker frank oma aus
hannover zum aller ersten mal haben wir
in gb 19 04 12 das unverkennbare
gravitationswellen brummen einer höheren
harmonischen gehört ähnlich den
obertönen von musikinstrumenten in
systemen mit ungleichem massen wie gw 19
04 12 unserer ersten beobachtung dieser
art sind diese obertöne in
gravitationswellen signal viel lauter
als in unseren üblichen signalen auch
einsteins vorhersage implizierte dass
diese obertöne im system mit ungleichen
massen viel lauter sein müssen als in
den verschmelzungen signalen zweier
schwarzer löcher die ebenbürtig sind
doch diese überraschende entdeckung ist
nach ansicht der forschungsteams wohl
nur der anfang
die fachleute gehen nämlich jetzt davon
aus dass es noch viele weitere solcher
systeme geben könnte und das obwohl
einige modelle bis dann das gegenteil
behaupten dazu der physiker fanconi
jedem es saison von lego und soko hat
uns bisher neue einblicke in unser
universum eröffnet und die dritte
laufzeit ist keine ausnahme es ist
offensichtlich dass wir gerade erst
begonnen haben die vielfalt der paare
von schwarzen löchern dort draußen zu
verstehen die fachleute setzten darauf
dass in zukunft immer längere
beobachtungszeit möglich sind und auch
die detektoren immer sensitiver werden
wenn es tatsächlich gelingt weitere
ereignisse dieser art nachzuweisen
könnte das fachleute enorm weiter bringt
denn durch diese beobachtung lässt sich
nicht nur die entstehungsgeschichte
schwarzer löcher viel besser
nachvollziehen sondern auch die
expansionsgeschwindigkeit müssen wir
nicht einmal so lange warten bis die
technik weiter optimiert wurde denn die
forschungsteams der loburger kooperation
die sind optimistisch dass bereits
weitere spannende daten gesammelt werden
konnten
dazu der niederländische wissenschaftler
fanden brand ich denke die ernte ist
recht gut lassen sie es mich so sagen
in zahlen ausgedrückt bedeutet das
während der dritten beobachtungs
kampagne bis märz 2020 wurden insgesamt
56 mögliche gravitationswellen
ereignisse gemessen die daten von 54
davon warten noch darauf ausgewertet zu
werden
hier erklärt vikings also hier
gravitationswellen noch mal ganz genau
unbedingt anklicken anschauen und
unbedingt abonnieren hammer kanal bis
dann bleibt dran